biden's failures are going from bad to
worse
as a new poll from gallup finds that a
whopping 83 percent of americans are
dissatisfied with the direction of the
country all while biden's approval
remains at a dismal 41 percent with some
other polls having it as low as the mid
30s now this comes as the destructive
democrat agenda is failing on every
single front as we see every day in our
lives inflation is hovering at a 40-year
high gas prices continue to hit one
record high after another record numbers
of illegal immigrants are waltzing
across the southern border biden's weak
diplomacy is arousing evil dictators
across the globe all while crime
searches gun violence is plaguing our
streets and americans try to make sense
of biden's senseless presidency and what
is the president's solution to all these
growing crises
to further divide the country and to
surrender his uh uh and to surrender his
agenda to the far fringe left it's never
really been what agenda did he have
except to become president uh these are
the extremists in the democratic party
now for example yesterday biden signed
an executive order that in the midst of
all this appears to be just another
effort to demonize the cops
one law enforcement official told fox
news it was a quote political response
to activist demands well what's new now
the order includes things like
implementing a new quote new evidence
informed annual anti-bias
training requirement
and quote reimagines crisis response oh
we've heard that before
it's not good
uh so i don't whatever what does that
mean but just like clockwork the
president the resident grifters over at
black lives matter used the occasion to
launch more smears against the police
with the group tweeting quote
maintaining a white supremacist
institution like policing costs black
lives this continued commitment by
politicians to support our killers makes
them accessories to our demise you know
of course unless you're living in a six
million dollar mansion like like they
are here for reaction fox news
contributor leo terrell along with
america first legal founder stephen
miller leo let me start with you
uh we're we we are involved in these
issues on the front lines we are regular
americans we have like great jobs i love
the job i do you've been an activist and
a community person
all of your adult life uh and both of us
on the wrong side for a period of time
but this really i'd like you to address
the the
the seemingly cancerous nature of how
none of this stops and how it seems to
be like boring into wanting more
disaster after more disaster after more
disaster
thank you tammy for having me i'm glad
to be on with stephen as well look joel
bite is an empty suit you said it tammy
he's taking his marching orders from the
extreme left
he is doing absolutely nothing to help
the average american citizen because the
extreme left has already doubled down on
this disastrous economic policy
it's just horrific what he did yesterday
with the stephen with the uh george
floyd act executive order
toothless tammy you know why because
it's it doesn't address state and local
officers it's all his power is only over
the federal officers and the sad part
about it
is that
donald trump and tim scott try to get
police reform legislation steve will
tell you that and guess who blocked it
uh cory booker kamala harris you know
why because they didn't want
to allow president trump and tim scott
to show that they believe in police
reform when necessary so you get a
toothless executive order it's
meaningless and i'll tell you right now
joe biden and name only as president but
the extreme left is running this country
and we see the results stephen with all
those disasters we all know as they are
playing out they're not even like
staying static
they're getting worse over time and we
all know we're not surprised and so
there's something afoot it's not there's
no effort to even just like let's just
keep it at a 20-year high it goes to a
40-year high
is this just incompetence or do you see
this as part perhaps of an agenda that
is being deliberately implemented at
this point
no the body administration is
effectively run by marxist
revolutionaries there's no poll that's
going to stop them being voted out of
power is the only thing the only thing
that's going to stop them every day they
show up to work asking themselves how
can i advance another radical marxist
directive let's talk about that policio
here's something people are not
discussing in that executive order it
restricts the federal government from
providing surplus military equipment to
our police departments something
president trump was on the exact
opposite side of making sure they have
that equipment why does it matter well
if somebody comes to your school and
starts shooting you want police officers
to get there on the scene in 60 seconds
with the best armor the best equipment
the most powerful weaponry they have to
obliterate to obliterate that school
shooter why in god's name why in god's
name now of all times that we take away
this equipment from our police officers
it's just one radical directive after
another with no thought for what it does
to the lives of everyday citizens yeah
and it would say
also when you think about the disturbed
or a young man who's really mad and all
you hear is talk about defunding the
police and law enforcement's evil you
know they're underfunded you know they
don't have what they need
that probably makes it a tiny bit easier
to take a chance that you normally
wouldn't take if the police were going
to come down on you like a hammer cops
we are all less safe and thousands more
will needlessly be killed in street
crime because the police are being told
to pull back and not do their jobs
you know leo do you think this is a
factor and you know it's more of a
a kind of an undercurrent factor when
when criminals and others you know we
have the horrible shooting on the subway
here in new york crime in los angeles
continues these home invasion robberies
the school shooting the slaughter of of
children uh is this do you think this is
part of this cultural rhetoric that the
left has moved that that encourages and
inspires the disturbed
oh absolutely let me tell you right now
the the criminals are elated with
democratic leadership in these cities
every day we talk about the crime and
i'll tell you right now the reason is
very simple they want to destroy
everything that's good about this
country steven said it best these are
marxists who want to destroy every
institution they want to destroy the
police department black lives matter let
me be very clear about them they got no
credibility i hope every ag in the state
investigate them when there is that
tsunami landslide victory by the
republican party please investigate blm
they have no credibility they don't
speak for any person in this country
other than their mansions and let me
tell you gentlemen thank you you know
this is all of this kind of rhetoric the
people doing the worst things are hoping
it's going to they're going to raise
money this is about what's sexiest and
what gets people most emotional and how
they can manipulate and use and all of
them came to the front because they
don't want to be left out of the money
that can be raised this is an americans
have had enough
moms have had enough families have had
enough
so uh thank you both for joining me i
appreciate it gentlemen hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else